ce n'est pas une faute mais un crime les
avocats des associations des muffins
veulent maintenant un procès en assises
pour les responsables du centre national
de transfusion sanguine
selon un rapport confidentiel c'est en
toute connaissance de cause que des
médecins auraient donc laissé en
circulation en 85 du plasma contaminé
par le virus du sida
reportage d'hervé ghesquière la menace
de la cour d'assises le mot crime
lancé par l'association française des
hémophiles la tension monte dans la
sphère des malades transfusés contaminés
par le sida avant 1985
les échantillons de plasma étaient
infectées et pourtant certaines
autorités le savent et des documents
confidentiels rédigés par des médecins
en 1985 préconisé le chauffage du plasma
pour inactiver le virus du sida mais
aucune décision rapide n'a été prise au
banc des accusés le centre national de
transfusion sanguine
le laboratoire national de la santé et
le ministère de la santé
aujourd'hui un des avocats des malades
proteste on a délibérément laissé sur le
marché des substances dont un dont on
savait qu'elle était extrêmement
dangereuse c'est constitutif d'un crime
et d'un crime volontaire et d'ailleurs
la jurisprudence a étendu la l'intention
de nuire à la simple acceptation
consciente d'un danger la question qui
se pose est la suivante le cnts les
pouvoirs publics
le docteur garetta savait-il de façon
consciente que les produits étaient
dangereux
la réponse est un conte 16
incontestablement oui
le ministre de la santé de l'époque
edmond hervé actuel maire de rennes
demeure obstinément muet sur cette
affaire pourtant depuis 1985 171 malades
contaminés sont morts du sida
les hémophiles réclame donc assistance
pour les familles dans ces 171 décès et
à 30% de marier la fin de démo fils qui
était marié avec des charges de famille
il faut donc assurer à ces familles
le moyen de vivre décemment quelques
malades ont reçu une indemnité de 100
mille francs
mais la plupart demandent justice et
refuse le prix du silence